hello everyone and welcome to a truly
spectacular game that happened yesterday
in the speed chess championship match
between nihal sarin and ding lyron uh
it's uh standard as in every match we've
covered so far so first hour and a half
of five plus one uh Blitz then three
plus one Blitz one hour and then 30
minutes of bullet not real bullet but
one plus one still pretty pretty fast
and it uh definitely made a a big impact
on the final score now uh regarding the
incident or it's not really an incident
but why nihala resigned it's dingler is
one of the players that has the worst
internet connection in the world he
always uh gets disconnected and loses
the game but uh here is is the one such
occasion where uh the well uh sort of
the favor was returned nihal Salin uh
one game after uh dingler and
disconnected uh resigned the game after
only three moves were played giving back
the point he didn't want to win like
this and it was a definitely a class act
as uh well ding earlier and is amazingly
strong and someone would try to take
advantage of an opportunity like this
but not nehal he shows that he truly is
a a true Class Act and well it's just a
very very impressive that he did it
right away now getting back to the
actual game this is the second the game
that was played from the five plus one
Blitz section it's absolutely
spectacular it lasts only 19 moves but
the best part of the game is of course
as usual the the part that you don't see
and what happened in this game the part
you don't see uh will just blow your
mind so let's dive straight into it Niha
has the white pieces and he opens with e
for dingos for the Sicilian Defense Pawn
to C5 Knight to F3 we have D6 and now
Knight the C3 not going for the uh
Central breakthrough with D4 right away
Knight to F6 and now usually we would
see D4 after we've postponed it for one
move but nikhail now goes Pawn to E5 and
okay you're attacking the Knight the
thing of course will capture the captors
Sunny 5 Knight captures an E5 and A6 now
taking away the B5 Square from nihal's
pieces with G3 preparing to Finca to the
light Square bishop and now Queen to C7
attacking the Knight and E5 so D for now
C captures and queen captures and now
yes you will attack the queen while
developing the Knight but now nihal just
trades Knight captures on C6 and now
Queen captures on C6 it's a bit of a
difference you don't have to capture
with the B Pawn and it comes with tempo
as the rook and H1 is hanging but uh
check this out Bishop to G5 and this is
where things become incredibly
interesting now how do you how do you
play this of course uh if you capture
The Rook on H1 which is possible then
just Queen side castles and there are so
many threads here for white you just
can't uh Parry all of them uh most
obvious one of course Queen to d8
Checkmate and it's a very very easy term
uh uh very easy to to win this with
white whatever black plays for example
Bishop D7 looks like a good move now
you're stopping Checkmate but white can
easily eliminate the defender of the D7
bishop and again you have problems you
don't really have a good move um of how
to handle this it's uh not possible so
what ding did of course is go Bishop to
G4 and now this is a well-known line so
uh Bishop to G4 Bishop captures on F6
and now uh this is the position where
everyone goes wrong because this
position has been reached before and no
one knows how to play it that's uh I
mean it's amazing but it's true I've
checked multiple databases and no one
ever played this correctly because there
is only one good move here for black and
that is Pawn to H5 by capturing here on
F6 uh you no longer have your bishop and
G4 defended so you have to play H5 and
now you are preparing Rook to d8 even
though you want to play Rook to d8 right
away you can because of Queen captures
and G4 but now after H5 this is a threat
so look at this and also uh the The Rook
on each one is hanging so you have to
play Knight to D5 now Bishop to F3
attacks The Rook ended the Knight here
Bishop captures on G7 Bishop captures on
D5 bishop catras and h8 Bishop captures
and H1 now Rook to D1 stopping Rook to
d8 and now Bishop to F3 attacks The Rook
Rook to D3 attacks the bishop and the
bishop to G4 and you have this position
where white is up a pawn but this is
really not a position where you should
be counting pawns uh so that's how you
should play this H5 like I said
absolutely amazing no one has ever
played H5 here even though it's the only
good move for black ding goes for G
captures on F6 and I will just check
real quickly I didn't check when a win
uh an entirely new position appears so
I'm just gonna check it right now so
Queen captures on G4 of course grabbing
that um uh grabbing that piece but this
is where uh ding will realize that the
Rook can't really be captured or will he
because Queen capras and G4 still a
known move Queen characters on H1 also a
non-move the move that uh being played
and now we have a queen side castles
also a known move but there is only one
move that wins here for white and we're
gonna show it now and that of course is
Queen the A4 with check nihal missed it
as uh I mean it's uh very very difficult
to find all of this but I will show it
Queen to a for check wins because there
is no way to defend uh Queen to C6 uh
okay you block check but now Bishop to
B5 uh you either lose the queen or you
capture the bishop and then Queen
capture 78 with check King to D7 and now
Queen side castles comes with check King
has to go to E6 You're Gonna Play F4
stopping Bishop to H6 so you don't lose
your queen uh here on A8 and that's
pretty much it the king will not survive
for very long on E6 another thing you
could do after Queen to A4 with check
your don't have to block with the queen
you could also try to block with
something else you can't really move the
king if you play King to d8 then Queen
side castles again it comes with check
and it's going to be a first Checkmate
King C7 Queen D7 check King 38 Queen 38
check King A7 and now look at this
Knight to B5 with check only one move
for black eight captures on B5 and not
after Queen to A5 with the check and
King beat there's Rook to d8 Checkmate
so that's the second option you have
after Queen day for check and the third
one is B5 but now of course you know
that Knight captures on B5
uh will uh again in the game Bishop
characters is impossible because the
bishop is pinned uh but this is quite
sufficient there is no good move here
for Black Knight the C7 check is coming
and there's nothing you can do you can't
deliver a check the queen for me for
covers the E4 Square so you could try
something like Bishop to H6 okay it
prolongs the game a little bit but still
Knights the C7 checking a f8 you pick up
the rook and after Queen captures an A8
you play F4 and the bishop is out of the
game The Rook is out of the game the
king is in a terrible spot uh there's uh
not much what black can do here so this
was the only way to continue the game
however nihal castled here Queen side
which uh uh seems to be also a move that
has been played before it was played in
1975 in Novi Sad against Petra Popovich
and cross notarus and here after castles
Queen to C6 was played also the move
that the ding played uh and now uh in
the game that from 1975 uh Bishop the C4
was played but here we have knighted the
D5 and it is now as of move 14 that we
have a completely new game and it is the
absolute best move for white in this
position
uh so what can what can ding play here
now he can play Rook to d8 and he should
and he does Rook to d8 uh Bishop to G2
defending the Knight on D5 and now comes
Queen to C8 again the only way to play
this for ding now is H5 you have to kick
away the queen uh and then go Bishop to
H6 check you're gonna put the king and G
G7 probably and then get the Rook into
the game or maybe to a fade and put the
Rook on G8 something like that but in
the game Queen the C8 was played and
this is where the fun really begins now
nihal plays one of the most uh uh the
the destructive moves of the game he
plays King to B1 and what is this he
just uh hung his Queen and G4 but of
course the queen cannot be captured if
you capture the queen Knight to C7 a
beautiful Checkmate the King has no
squares the D7 square is covered by the
rook and that would be uh it so instead
E6 was played another way to play this
is Pawn to F5 but this is Blitz of
course uh making a more like one to F5
requires a tremendous amount of
calculation and I will show it because
it's super fun uh but now Queen to A4
with check and look at this B5 Queen to
D4 now remembering the queen to the
Central Square attacking The undefended
Rook on h8 F6 and now Knight the C7
check and you might think okay but what
is this uh well look at what it is a
queen captures on C7 Queen capture 78
with check Queen capture 78 and now not
root capture 78 but rather Bishop the C6
check and now after the king moves King
to S7 you will pick up the queen and now
it doesn't really matter what you play
there is um a way to continue the game
for black and that is Pawn to B4 uh but
uh I mean uh it's impossible to find all
this and white would still be much
better but just to give you an example
if you got something like Bishop to G7
you want to trade Bishop to D5 check now
with E6 um you will just deliver a nice
check and then pick up the pawn so we're
gonna move the king and then let's say
Rook captures Bishop captures and now
Pawn to B4 uh locks the pawns and light
squares and now the bishop will just
gobble them up and of course you also
understand why black should have played
uh Ponte V for himself on that move in
this theoretical uh line uh but okay
after King to B1 ding does not play this
he goes for Pawn to E6 and now nihal
just completely crashes through Knight
captures on F6 with check King to E7 and
now there is only one winning move for
nikal and it's not the easiest one to
spot so feel free to pause the video and
win the game for nihal while I give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting This
brilliant maneuver and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
Queen the B4 with check uh leaving the
king uh no other options as all of the
squares are taken by the Knight and by
the rook and by the queen uh then to
capture the undefended Knight on F6 you
can block with anything this is
impossible the these six square is
covered by the queen and by The Rook so
King captures an F6 and now nihal just
played Queen to H for with check and he
was in this position on move 19 that
dingler and resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here
absolutely spectacular game by nihal and
you've seen how difficult this line is
if you ever encounter it you will know
that H5 move for black is an absolute
must if you want to survive this with
black but even uh by missing the actual
forcing win in that position with Queen
to A4 uh you see how how incredibly
difficult it was to play this uh with
black now the reason why you resign here
is King E5 runs into Checkmate in one
Queen to Air Force Checkmate if you go
King to F5 first you deliver one check
Force the king to E5 and then Queen Tab
4 will be Checkmate and if you don't
wanna get checkmated like this you can
play King to G6 but it's not much better
look at this Rook capture 78 the queen
from H4 also covers the d8 square and
now wherever the queen goes doesn't
really matter you will always do the
same thing Queenie for check King to H6
and now Queen E3 check King to G6 just
setting up Checkmate and now Rook to E8
looks like a weird move but you are
actually taking away the E7 Square from
the black king now it doesn't matter
what uh black plays so to give you an
example let's say Bishop G7 you want to
trade Rooks you wanna uh alleviate the
pressure a little bit Queenie for check
King to F6 and now Queen to H4 with
check King to F5 and now Bishop to E4
with check King E5 You're Gonna Play
Queen to F for check this also nicely
connects with the queen and C7 King to
D4 C3 check King wherever it doesn't
really matter Queen captures C7 with
King B5 now Queen captures and B7 with
check King somewhere and now you can
either play Queen to B for checkmate or
queen the A6 Checkmate but since on this
channel we really like the B4 Square
we're gonna say it's Queen to B for
checkmate that's that that's why adding
resigned after Queen H4 check and what a
spectacular game by nihal sarin only 19
moves even though it seems much much
longer because of all the uh the lines
that we've explored but absolutely
spectacular stuff but not only that he
returned the favor favor as being
disconnected in the five plus one
section so he resigned after playing
only three moves which makes his victory
over ding not only in this game but also
the match even more spectacular now in
the five plus one section they were
pretty pretty equal even though okay uh
and and he'll return the point in three
plus one uh nihal was better but when it
came to Bullet nihal just completely
obliterated ding the the final resulting
bullet was seven and a half to one and a
half in nihal's favor and the final
result of the match was nine points ding
17 points nihal so uh definitely a
crushing Victory uh in this uh uh well a
wild match sorry about not posting
anything yesterday but it was just too
loud in Croatia everyone was celebrating
I was also watching the game I I I don't
uh usually follow football but I watch
it like when there's the World Cup when
when Croatia is playing um and then uh
well since everyone else is watching it
that's pretty much any everything
everyone is talking about
um I I watch it as well but uh
yesterday's game Croatia versus Brazil I
I I I enjoy it thoroughly not gonna
comment on it because uh I really don't
know much about football but uh I I
really enjoyed it like it was so intense
uh the the you know the first 90 minutes
and then the the overtime and and the
penalties I mean it was such a nail
biter I don't know I I tried to try to
uh you know compare it with with some
historic chess match or even a chess
game uh but I don't know nothing comes
to mind if you guys have anything uh do
share in the comments I'm sure we would
uh we would all enjoy that uh but yeah
that's the game I hope you guys enjoyed
it once again big congratulations to
nikal and the spectacular Victory I
would like to thank ravishing reptiles
YouTube home uh anubav katiela Croatia
and Nikolai pokrovsky for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the speechers
championship and everything else that
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day